Formula One is basically
my life, my world.
I like to battle against the world's
fastest 19 other drivers.
No other thing makes me
happier than driving.
When Formula One held its
first Chinese Grand Prix in Shanghai,
five-year-old Zhou
Guanyu was in the stands
cheering on his idol Fernando Alonso.
Now, Zhou is competing against Alonso
after he became China's first
full-time F1 racer last year.
I really started to fall in love
with racing my first ever attempt
or try when I was a kid
around seven years old.
We went to an indoor go-kart track
and I was actually very scared.
I was sitting in the two seater go-kart
my dad was driving.
But then, the first time I tried it,
I absolutely fell in love with the sport
and I really want to do it
every weekend after school.
As a kid, I grew up having that dream.
The most challenging part
for me in Formula One is
is probably before the first race.
A lot of people were doubtful about me,
saying I won't be fast, I'll be last.
But for me, I was just really focused.
I knew I deserved to be there.
And to get my first points
in my first season is amazing.
Zhou is a very, very talented driver.
We have been following
him from the junior category.
We were fully convinced that
he can be a very strong
addition to our team,
and he confirmed our
expectation last year.
Imagine a rookie, coming to Formula One
and being able to score points
at the very first race.
To have a Chinese driver of such a level
is beneficial not only for our team,
but for the entire Formula One.
But that hasn't translated into
comparable dollars for the franchise.
The cancelation of the Chinese Grand Prix
for a fourth straight year in 2023
has been another setback.
But Zhou's emergence
might be the key to turning things around.
Now in his second season,
Zhou has already attracted
sponsorship deals from global brands.
Any international sports coming to China,
for it to truly become popular,
it needs to have relevance.
And nothing builds relevance
like having your own superstar
and champion to support.
We've seen that in other sports,
basketball, with the
emergence of Yao Ming,
tennis and Li Na,
how those superstars on the global stage,
have really boosted the sport.
Now we have Zhou Guanyu
on the grid of Formula One,
that will also stimulate
commercial interest.
Hopefully, when Formula One
comes back to China next year,
it will start to really reap the rewards
and grow the popularity.
For me to be the first Chinese
or the only Chinese in F1,
I definitely see what's
happened back home.
It's been quite incredible
seeing how many people
that are staying up late
to watch the Grand Prix.
And now all we need is a Grand Prix
in front of the home crowd.
because there's so many new fans
who doesn't know anything
about motorsports
now actually getting into that.
Watching or trying to understand F1.
Traditionally, it costs
quite a lot of money
to develop a driver from a young age.
An increasingly wealthy middle class
will mean you'll have a growing community
that will be interested in their children,
perhaps becoming Formula One drivers.
There will be many, many Chinese people
competing in motorsport and
Formula One in the future.
I'm only optimistic that things
can get better from here.